Mrs Obama yes I would love to ask you
about waffles and mochi as far as when
you became first lady and you started
the let's move campaign and you were
building Gardens and schools you did
become synonymous with veggies
and you made me think differently about
schools and Gardens and veggies so when
they brought you this project did it
feel
ever so authentic to you it so did Drew
I mean this is sort of the culmination
of everything we worked on in the White
House really trying to make the exposure
to food fun and now through our our work
with Higher Ground and Netflix we've got
this amazing show that is a food
Adventure that continues that journey
and we are working with some fun
characters waffles and mochi they are my
Sidekicks and in the first season they
learned all about food because they
wanted to become chefs and guess what
they're doing this season
are they opening a restaurant they are
opening their own restaurant I they have
become chefs what was it for you was
there someone or something that opened
you up to Why being healthy is so
important because as a parent you'll
feed your kid anything in order not to
well Bonk or go crazy and sometimes
fruits and veggies aren't always
available well I was in your position
you know if you remember now my girls
are grown women out in the world but
when we entered the White House they
were seven and ten so I was in that
position when I was I was working I had
a full-time job I was campaigning for my
husband I was on the road and I was
getting to the point where I couldn't
figure out how to feed my kids healthy
foods because I was trying to do what
most parents were doing give them
something fast and quick and I saw my
kids health being affected by the fact
that we did too much fast food we did
too many sugary drinks and as I've
always said it's about balance it's not
that we can't have fun but when fun is
what you do so I struggle with that as a
parent and I figured here I am college
educated law degree and I don't know
what to feed my kids what's healthy so I
set out to embrace this issue to educate
us as a nation but to also help parents
you know learn what works for their kids
so may I please
um ask if I could we could all meet the
stars of the most important show well
yeah a show I think is destined to
become the next Sesame Street
waffles and mochi
you are
oh hi everybody
yeah that's right Mochi we're so excited
aren't we happy to be here guys
[Music]
waffles and mochi may I ask what your
favorite food is my
my yeah how could I
just one miss Barrymore oh I know it's
so hard it is so hard but you know
we talked a little bit about chocolate
and vanilla on the show raise your hand
if you like chocolate
and
vanilla
[Music]
you probably have to be one of my faves
and learning that they go well together
yeah yeah that's just the cherry on top
just like you and mochi you go well
together we Are Better Together aren't
we
waffles what would be one food that we
should try to remember to feed our kids
I know that's hard there's so many
that's a good
that's if it's full of delicious
vitamins and minerals yeah yeah and and
you can make a rainbow on your plate
right Mrs Obama yeah I ask you a rapid
fire group of questions rapid fire okay
we've got to get serious you got this
Mrs oh all right it's time for the final
five
scary all right your favorite veggie
broccoli
your favorite food fact food fact oh oh
that there are over a thousand different
varieties of bananas
a thousand I didn't know that yeah we'll
have to watch our episode otherwise
known as Nana's yeah what's your
favorite pizza topping uh cheese
[Laughter]
now we love cheese cheese definitely
loves cheese um what is your favorite
food memory oh you know my mom used to
bake homemade cakes for us for our
birthdays and that was part of our
birthday you know and my mom even did
this when she lived with us in the White
House is there a new or is there a hype
song I could listen to tomorrow morning
when I'm working out to think of you
anything Beyonce thank you I did that
this morning okay yeah me too that was
my Drive-In her new song that samples I
feel loved by Donna Summer oh yeah oh
that song it's fire it's fire okay it is
does everyone want to get up and switch
their legs and dance a little bit
foreign thank you
Mochi and thank you Mrs Obama
[Music]